obviously we want to be wealthy and we
want to get there in this lifetime
without having to rely on luck a lot of
people think making money is about luck
it's not it's about becoming the kind of
person that makes money you know I like
to think that if I lost all my money and
if you drop me on a random street in any
English-speaking country within five to
ten years I'd be wealthy again right
because it's just a skill set that I've
developed and I think anyone can develop
you know in a thousand parallel
universes you want to be wealthy in 999
of them you don't want to be wealthy the
50 of them where you got lucky so we
want to factor luck out of it there's
really four kinds of luck that we were
talking about this came from a book P
Marca uh Mark Andreessen wrote a blog
post about it but basically there's
different kinds of luck the first kind
of luck you might just say is like blind
luck where I just got lucky because
something completely out of my control
happened you know that's Fortune that's
fate Etc then there's luck that kind of
comes through persistence hard work
hustle motion when which is when you're
just running around creating lots of
opportunities you're generating a lot of
energy you're doing a lot of things lots
of things will just get stirred up in
the dust it's almost like mixing a petri
dish and seeing what combines or mixing
a bunch of reagents and seeing what
combines you're just generating enough
force and hustle and energy that luck
will sort of find you we as a group You
could argue got together because of that
you know denad had put up these great
videos online I saw them on Twitter and
so in that sense he sort of generated
his own luck by just creating videos
until people like me keep finding him a
third way is that you just become very
good at spotting luck
so if you are very skilled in a field
you will notice when a lucky break
happens in that field when other people
who aren't attuned to it won't notice so
you become sensitive to luck and that's
through skill and knowledge and work and
then the last kind of luck is the
weirdest hardest kind but that's what we
want to talk about which is where you
build a unique character a unique brand
a unique mindset where then luck finds
you for example let's say that you're
the best person in the world at Deep Sea
underwater diving and you're known to
like take on Deep Sea underwater die as
if nobody else will even attempt to DARE
and then by sheer luck somebody finds a
sunken treasure ship off the coast they
can't get at well their luck just became
your luck because they're going to come
to you to get that treasure and you're
gonna get paid for it now that's an
extreme example but it's just showing
how like the person who got lucky by
Finding the Treasure Chest that was
blind luck but them coming to you and
asking you to extract it and having to
give you half that's not luck you kind
of created your own luck you put
yourself in a position to be able to
capitalize on that luck or to attract
that luck when nobody else has created
that opportunity for themselves so when
we talk about without getting lucky we
want to be deterministic we don't want
to leave with the chance I think it's
pretty interesting that the first three
kinds of luck that you described there
are very common cliches for them that
everybody knows and then for that last
kind of luck that comes to you out of
the unique way that you act there's no
real cliche for it so for the first
three kinds there's dumb luck or blind
luck that's the first kind of luck the
second kind of luck is the cliche that
fortune favors the Bold that's a person
who gets lucky just by stirring the pot
and acting the Third Kind of luck people
say that Chance favors the prepared mind
but for The Fourth Kind of luck there is
not really a common cliche out there
that matches the unique character
director of Your Action which I think is
interesting and perhaps an opportunity
and it also just shows that people
aren't necessarily taking advantage of
that kind of luck the way they should be
I think also at that point it starts
becoming so deterministic that it stops
being luck so the definition starts
fading from luck to more Destiny so I
would characterize that fourth one is
you build your character in a certain
way and then your character becomes your
destiny one of the things I think that
is important to making money you want
the kind of reputation that makes people
do deals through you you know I use the
example of like if you're a great diver
then treasure hunters will come and give
you a piece of treasure for your diving
skills if you're a trusted reliable high
integrity long-term thinking deal maker
than when other people want to do deals
but they don't know how to do them in a
trustworthy manner with strangers they
will literally approach you and give you
a cut of the deal or offer you a unique
deal just because of the integrity and
reputation that you built up Warren
Buffett he gets offered deals and he
gets to buy companies and he gets to buy
warrants and bail out Banks and do
things that other people can't do
because of his reputation but of course
that's fragile it has accountability on
the line it has a strong brand on the
line and as we will talk about later
that comes with accountability attached
but I would say you know character your
reputation these are things that you can
build that then will let you take out
advantages of opportunities that other
people may characterize as lucky but you
know that it wasn't you said that
this Fourth Kind of luck is more or less
a destiny there's a quote from that
original book that was in uh Mark's blog
post from Benjamin Disraeli who I think
was the former prime minister of the UK
the quote to describe this kind of luck
was we make our fortunes and we call
them fate there were a couple other
interesting things about this kind of
luck that were mentioned in the blog
post I think it'll be good for the
listeners to hear about is that this
Fourth Kind of luck can almost come out
of eccentric ways that you do your
things and that eccentricity is not
necessarily a bad thing in this case in
fact it's a good thing yeah absolutely
because the world is a very efficient
place so everyone has dug through all
the obvious places to dig and so to find
something that's new and novel and
uncovered it helps to be operating on a
Frontier where right there you have to
be a little eccentric to be out on the
frontier by yourself and then you just
have to to be willing to dig deeper than
other people do deeper than seems
irrational just because you're
interested yeah the two quotes that I've
seen that Express this kind of luck in
addition to that Benjamin Disraeli won
are this one from Sam Altman where he
said extreme people get extreme results
I think that's pretty nice and then
there's this other one from Jeffrey
pfeffer who's a professor at Stanford
that you can't be normal and expect
abnormal returns I've always enjoyed
that one too yeah and the one quote that
I like which is the exact opposite of
that is play stupid games Win stupid
prizes right A lot of people spend a lot
of their time playing social games like
on Twitter where you're just trying to
improve your social standing and you
basically win stupid social prizes which
are worthless I guess the last thing
that I have from this blog post is just
the idea that by pursuing these kinds of
luck especially the last one basically
everything but dumblr by pursuing them
you essentially run out of unlock so if
you just keep stirring the pot and
stirring the pot that alone you will run
out of unlock yeah or it could just be
reversion to the mean right so then you
at least neutralize luck so that it's
your own talents that come into play now
when I make some Reflections about this
kind of look that comes from one's own
unique character personally I follow a
particular framework to develop this
unique skill set I first learned about
this framework from Team fairies and it
consists in the following when you're
thinking about starting any project
think about what skills could you
develop or improve by doing the project
if you can identify one or more
important skills then you should be more
willing to take the project because even
if you end up not succeeding you still
will have developed skills that can be
useful to you in future projects let's
hear it from Tim ferries himself but
here is the rationale the rationale was
or rather the question that I would ask
myself is like
is there a way that I can win doing this
even if I fail
and the way that I win doing something
even if I fail is if I develop skills
and relationships are deep in
relationships that transcend that
project as a failure does that make
sense yep Scott Adams writes a lot about
this really well team applied this
framework when deciding to whether he
should start the podcast or not he was
able to see that the podcast would make
him better at interviewing and asking
questions which is an important skill in
general and even the philosopher
Voltaire went to say judge a man by his
questions rather than his answers
besides Tim was a prolific book author
at the time so this skill would serve
him well when interviewing people for
new books
so as you go executing different
projects over time and stacking up new
skills with each new project you become
increasingly more unique because less
people will be able to match your skill
set and as navarrovican said it's even
better if you're genuinely interested in
those projects because you will go
deeper than other people and it will
feel like play to you rather than work
Scott Adams argued that he was never the
best at any particular skill but he was
the best at something in which he was
able to apply many acquired skills he
was able to combine his average
knowledge in design writing comedy and
business skills to produce his most
successful project Dilbert so the most
deterministic and less competitive way
to get rich is to keep learning skills
and finding ways to combine them so that
you can be the best at what you do as
Robert Greene wrote on his book Mastery
the future belongs to those who learn
more skills and combine them in creative
ways I want to also mention that when
I'm doing things and learning new skills
I try not to fix say too much on the
part particular relevance of those
skills to My Future Self because as
Steve Jobs said it's impossible to
connect the dots looking forward we can
only connect them looking backwards so
just have faith that somehow those new
skills will eventually connect and
become useful to my future self and if
you want to prepare yourself and learn
skills faster I recommend you to check
out short form shofen create super
insightful study guides from hundreds of
non-fiction books and it has helped me
to discover and learn ideas much faster
the cost is equivalent to the price of
one book a month and you can use my
affiliate link shortform.com picking
nuggets to get a 5 day free trial and a
20 discount on the annual subscription
you can also find the link in the
description below